cordoba is famous for having the most
beautiful interior courtyards in Spain
where they're called patios every year
in the first week of May
the annual patio festival gets underway
local resident Rafael Cordoba is among
those taking part he's putting the
finishing touches on the flowerpots and
sprucing up the plants on his patio I
have four hundred flower pots so that's
a lot of wilted leaves to remove when
you're not busy watering you're applying
fertilizer or paint the house is very
old from the 16th century Lopez is also
doing some last-minute tidying up before
the visitors starts streaming in she
shows us her trusted and traditional
watering system a long stick and a tin
can at a fairly bought this property
just a short time ago we decided to buy
the house so that we can preserve this
old patio it's at least 350 years old
courtyard in Cordoba go back to Roman
times designed to provide houses with a
cool refuge from the heat the tradition
was continued by the Moors who built the
great mosque and now Cathedral and left
a lasting impact on local architecture
despite the city returning to Christian
rule in 1236 color the colors and scents
came from the Arabs they did their thing
they loved these vertical gardens but
they wanted to keep them to themselves
they closed the doors and enjoyed their
patio easy for power games
most of the city's four thousand
courtyards are still closed today but 60
open up to visitors during the 14-day
festival that means long queues outside
homes like Raphael cordobas but the wait
is well worth it beautiful we're here
for the first time and we like it that
we've only seen three or four I didn't
expect it to be this nice it's rather
unique you really have to be in the
patios to understand the colors the
scents and the light it's wonderful
not just locals and tourists visit the
courtyards the festival is also a
contest and so a judging panel stops by
to cast their votes for the best patios
there are different categories for
historical patios and more contemporary
ones this year 47 courtyards are in
competition one of the judges is
biologist and for her it's about more
than just the lovely colors
of course the variety of flowers plays a
role but it's the atmosphere that really
matters the water the music and what we
can smell as we come in it's all about
that initial emotion the first courtyard
festival was celebrated in 1918 it dates
back to a time when large single-family
villas were turned into multi-family
homes the rooms were so small that
people spent a lot of time in the
courtyards residents would decorate
their entrances painting the flowerpots
as they liked and because it was
particularly delightful in the
springtime they decided to open their
doors to visitors so they could see all
the beauty on display it's obvious
the crowds have been coming ever since
locals like Rafael make a huge effort to
make their prized patios even more
beautiful to win over the judges he's
won countless awards but his real
motivation is the memories there were
flowers here when I was a kid my
grandparents have since died I want to
keep the patio and flowers alive in
their memory every year people come from
far and wide to witness this unique
spectacle when the courtyards of Cordoba
spring into bloom